from your time on set watching other dps
what have you seen great DPS do before
during and after a scene because you're
so observant as well but also just being
around it's an intimate experience the
DP and actor relationship because you're
literally staring down the barrel of
something right at them getting what
they're doing and I think the great dps
are the ones that understand that and
they treat it with three the situation
with as much respect as possible
especially in some tough situations when
you're doing like a love scene or
something really emotional it's hard for
people who are not an actor to
understand what it's like to get into a
mindset like that and to have the world
around them and the world in the frame
be that world as good as possible so
that the audience will believe it it's
tough on a movie set it's not really the
environment it's not a very romantic
environment a movie set you know there's
a ton of people standing around is
staring at you and it's awkward and it
takes really a lot of concentration in a
lot of effort and if your air about you
as a cinematographer is that this world
that you're capturing is protected and
you make them feel that that is a
protected environment that the actors
can be free and comfortable in then that
really helps them a lot I think to to
divorce themselves from any distractions
that might be a present on set as well
and that way they can do their job as
good as possible and that's what I've
learned from a lot of the great better
dps that I've worked with is that if you
can make the environment really
comfortable for the actor and let them
know that you're being there being taken
care of or that's the bottom line and
then after after you say cut after you
say cut I think I've developed a
relationship with some actors that I
worked with where I can I can sort of
give them a look and it's not something
I intentionally do or even do on purpose
it's just like if I felt it a lot of
times I show that on my face somehow I
can't help it I'm not a good poker
player I I will
I will like amote somehow and I think
that sense it a lot of times people
couple actors that I work with on a
regular basis we have a relationship
where he'll look over at me after a
performance and he'll know whether he
did it right or not it's not what it's
not even sometimes whether his
performances right but how he was
situated or whatever in a price
shouldn't be talking about this stuff
but you know that's important you know
to make sure that whatever they were
doing was captured right and if I felt
like I didn't get it right enough I
don't want to I don't want to like let
that go and just beat around the bush on
it I want to be honest with them even
non-verbally to let them know needs to
be done again or it could be better I
think that's a somewhat of a
responsibility of the DP as well whether
they know it or not or sometimes it just
happens to be the case you know the
director said decision is always final
and it always is the most important
decision because there are the ones
seeing the big picture of the film and
sometimes there's other things going on
time and money wise but I think for a
few times I've been I've been I've
risked being the one at fault so that
the actor could get another take like I
blamed myself for something I was out of
focus and I you know just so we get one
more and it ultimately is not going to
hurt anybody and it's actually going to
help them in the editing room if you
have another take usually it's that's a
real good thing so maybe they'll be mad
at me for a short period of time where
or maybe I've caused a small hiccup just
for a second but if I was able to help
get one more good one that everybody was
in sync and in harmony on including the
sound people and you know sometimes as a
cinematographer you're in the position
to help someone like that if the sound
people didn't get it you know and if its
ass if it's a difficult political
situation on set I found myself
sometimes taking the heat for things
where you know you want to make sure
that everybody gets the best version of
what they're doing on screen but
sometimes it's a difficult political
situation for one or two people or three
people or whatever and you can help each
other out that way
no it's probably like a secret you
should be telling people but yeah it
happens every now and then and I think
that's something that you can attest to
being focused on the final product more
than anything and making sure that's the
best thing possible so just to recap the
thing a DP should be doing beforehand
during and after okay I'll make it brief
so before I think you should be making
sure the environment for the actor is
very comfortable what they feel like
they're being taken care of in front of
the camera during the take I think you
should be really observant and pay very
close attention to what the actor is
doing even outside of the frame it's the
challenging thing to do when you're
trying to do all kinds of technical
stuff as well but if you can do that
then I think you're you know higher up
level of cinematographer and then after
the fact I think you can assist the
actor and feeling comfortable that that
take was right and I think if it wasn't
right you can be honest with them
sometimes obviously it's a case-by-case
basis with I think it's important to
make sure that the film is the best film
possible at your job is a
cinematographer to be capturing the best
thing you possibly can for the director
and if you feel that it wasn't right
it's tough because it isn't a subjective
opinion and you know it might have been
right for the directory in which case
you can state your opinion but I'll
ultimately defer to the directors choice
and that's cool because sometimes that
actually most the time director knows
better than you anyway but if you do
feel like something technical happened
or whatever and I think it's important
to be honest about that and to make sure
that you know nobody's going to get in
trouble in the editing room
because that's that's a big that's a
real bad thing when when everyone thinks
everything's all jolly and then they get
in the editing room me like what
happened here you know that's a problem
for you as a professional to have caused
some issue and post so try to avoid that
as often as possible by over providing
the choices essentially for the director
and the editor a part of that is just
like I said being honest and having
somewhat of a you know back and forth
nonverbal relationship sometimes of the
actor whether you know they can they can
tell just by how you are I mean I don't
know how this is if this is the case for
everybody so I'm just telling you how it
works for me but a lot of times for me
that's how it works so and I the
directors know this too that I work with
I have enough rapport with them and they
are aware of what I do enough to know
that this is part of how it is with this
you know when i'm on project with them
and ultimately the best interest of the
project is always at the forefront of my
mind and at the directors mine so
collaborative effort is as needed there
as well and sometimes if there is a
problem with an actor with the director
you can help maybe mediate that by
providing again a comfortable
environment for the actor to begin and
you know you just gotta
navigate those things very carefully
you